airbus qui rit boeing qui pleure le
consortium européen enregistré
aujourd'hui la plus grosse commande de
l'histoire de l'aéronautique au bourget
12 milliards et demi d'euros venant de
la compagnie emirates qui a réservé 41
avions elle pour l'instant le carnet de
commandes de boeing est vide
patrick esther le hic le moigne
les deux gladiateurs sont dans l'arène
mais seuls l'européen airbus fait voler
ses avions
exhibant le plus puissant d'entre eux le
3 146 ans qui réalise ici un décollage
ultra court malgré ses 360 tonnes
ce matin une escadrille entière
d'appareils comme celui ci a été
commandé par la compagnie miracles
et ce n'est pas tout car tandis que dans
le ciel les pilotes rivalisent de
virtuosité dans le ballet des limousines
et la discrétion des chalets les
commerciaux en costume-cravate négocient
les contrats âprement dans ce monde
impitoyable airbus ce matin a fait
exploser ses ventes
oui c'est la plus grosse commande qu'on
n'est jamais rentré peut-être même la
plus grosse en une seule fois de
l'aviation civile puisqu'elle représente
en prix catalogue environ enfin un peu
plus de 10 milliards de dollars
et donc elle comporte 41 avions gros
porteurs airbus 21 380 et 23 145 106 ans
notre plus gros avions actuels boeing en
reste cloué au sol de saisissement son
seul avion présent au bourget le 777 300
n'effectue aucune démonstration en vol
il faut une invitation spéciale pour
monter à bord et penaud jim le chef
pilote d'essai explique que cela ne sert
à rien de faire voler ici un avion
expérimental pour vendre des appareils
notez bien que boeing n'a enregistré
aucune commande de gros porteur depuis
le début de l'année et refuse de
communiquer ses prévisions pour 2003
ce qui se passe c'est qu'il ya une forte
crise du transport aérien nous sommes
très confiants que d'ici 2005 les
compagnies aériennes seront à nouveau
rentable et pourront commander des
avions
aujourd'hui nous avons au salon du
bourget le dernier né de la gamme 777
plus nous dévoilant des détails sur
notre nouvel avion le 7 sept
dreamliner tout ça nous sommes
extrêmement confiants sur l'avenir
ici le plus petit des airbus le 3,18
disparaît sous le plus gros des boeing
une image trompeuse car désormais le
numéro un mondial s'appelle bel et bien
airbus